cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com every once in a while you'll
be somewhere and you'll see there's one
house on the Block that is like I don't
care I'm putting up my political science
and they're typically 45 Pro Trump signs
there's this one house that I pass in
the area that'll have this flag of like
Trump standing over Eagles and like you
know he's like just like a caricature
but there are there's no equivalent for
Joe Biden there is maybe vote Joe Biden
because you like the Democrats but
there's not this same sort of belief in
his capabilities in my opinion and I
think that's just because people voted
for Joe Biden because they wanted to get
Trump out he was he was the anti-trump
guy they weren't necessarily so gung-ho
about Biden they just didn't like Trump
that much that they would vote for Biden
to get Trump out so they're not
incentivized to waive the Biden Flags or
buy some buy it and merch in the same
way that pro-trump voters were they're
definitely a lot of super fans they're
not like the Trump base that's for sure
right even like I remember there was a
lot of Obama emerged back in the day and
yeah mad hype Hillary Clinton she had a
bunch of stuff I'm with her H is all
everywhere yeah
um but I mean Dubai's never captured
that attention any of the times he's run
for president no no way if you live in a
neighborhood where
um people feel safe and comfortable to
put up political signage of different
diverse views uh consider yourself quite
fortunate
um coming from Portland Oregon if you
you didn't even if you expressed any
type of dissenting views your property
would be highly likely subjected to
violence or potentially even serious
violence like arson or such well let me
pull up the story real quick just uh put
it put a pin that we have this from the
post millennial leader in Richmond
Democrat Party group posted bomb threat
against Andy no Virginia talk the post
include an image of dynamite with Jarvis
writing description box on my way to the
Andy no event so you've experienced
stuff I think everyone knows directly
covering the extremism do you want to
elaborate on what you're talking about
uh well you know we because uh the last
has cultural dominance like and they
they face no sunshine or no
um social consequences for expressing
radical and hateful uh extremist beliefs
they just they're able to push it
further and further to the point where
you can have somebody who's I mean we're
not talking about somebody who's in
Black Block
um antifa type of group this is somebody
who's in a leadership role in the in the
Richmond City Democratic committee which
is the official
um party Democrat Party group in
Richmond Virginia feeling confident and
fine to put this type of posts publicly
um and in going back to what I was just
saying a moment ago
those uh leftists who feel empowered to
go and Destroy people's properties
because they're expressing a different
political view so you know my my heart
is warm just to hear Claire just talk
briefly about you know the different
type of political signs that she's seen
in places she lives don't take that for
granted if you're an American who lives
in one of those places consider yourself
lucky because there are places like
Portland Seattle obviously different
boroughs of New York where you you uh
potentially put yourself in your family
at risk for expressing a mainstream
political view
well and they had that guy whose biker
neighbor went and lit his uh Trump sign
on fire I mean there are places that
people do feel entitled to uh well there
were neighbors though like I live kind
of I just meant that he biked in the
area
um I I think it's interesting one of the
things that you're saying reminds me of
um in your book you talked about how
people uh especially Progressive groups
will travel to small towns and set up
coffee shops or or bookstores and sort
of become very visible in that sense and
that becomes sort of how they begin to
have influence and control areas so
there are times that people are
expressing their views because they're
relying on the tolerance and the the
community's ability to welcome them even
if they don't agree with them and then
they become sort of a destructive force
in and of themselves
oh yeah yeah we see this phenomenon all
the time people who
um who adhere to certain principle
tolerance and then the other side gains
power and that that uh is not
reciprocated back onto them and they
suffer as a result I mean conservatives
experience that a lot right we want to
welcome and protect all views of
expression but then you have those who
are calling for an overturning of the
entire system and a totalitarian system
where people are subject to violence
potentially or deaths for their views
and and I mean I'm not saying that's
manifested in real life necessarily
anywhere in the US but in there's
certain Pockets where those type of
sentiments are Salient to a population
and they're able to
um cause so much violence
and and destruction on those around them
and and those in the victims just have
no ability to counter
um in uh so so I was speaking in
Richmond because Richmond is a city that
um
has experience uh over the years a
really radical cultural shift to the
left I think a lot of that has to do
with the university there the Virginia
Commonwealth University they had months
of riots uh in 2020 like Portland and a
lot of the same parallels uh between
Portland and Virginia I I documented in
explored in the speech you have
um
so he elected local officials the mayor
of those on city council condoning
um the riots
um even going out to some of those
protests turned riots to participate and
give them support
um you have police whose ability to
um actually enforce the law is curtailed
by the local politicians and then
um you have outside agitators coming in
and without a lot of money and it just
creates I mean a lot of deed
stabilization I think I think one of the
questions one of the questions I was
asked when I spoke on Friday was like
could this happen again and I say well
yes obviously because the the same the
networks that were strengthened and
established in 2020 are not only still
there they're stronger now and there
might be a bit of protests and Riot
fatigue today but just give it a bit of
time and there will be some other George
Floyd type moment that's caught on video
um clipped exploited and blasted on
social media and I'll get people to the
streets well 2024 is around the corner
it is it is about that time yeah right
2020 BLM George Floyd election year 2024
this next summer but Richmond doesn't
have any more monuments to pull down
what is it going to do it could be
literally anywhere and the issue is the
media lies
so let's say um let's let's say
something like this 2024 and there's
like some dude working in his garage in
the suburbs of I don't know some let's
say Youngstown Ohio is in his garage and
then uh some dude sneaks into his garage
and say grabs a a power tool case a
couple hundred bucks and then runs for
it and this guy's been known to the
neighborhood so the dude calls the
police the guy's neighbor confronts the
guy and like stop grabs him and stops
them and they fight over the tool and
then the the dude who is stealing it you
know falls on his head and dies
the medial report that two white men
approached a man who was walking down
the street a black man and they
mercilessly beat him to death and then
you'll get your riots and then a month
later the video will be released from
their ring security camera showing the
guy robbing the house and it'll be just
like Ahmed Aubry and they will find any
story they can to create a racially
charged atmosphere that will result in
riots and then they'll use that to claim
racism or whatever and then the people
who are correctly calling out this story
does not you know follow that line
they'll say aha they're racist this
prove it don't vote for Republicans etc
etc yeah did you guys see the story it
was kind of inverse to that of course it
didn't get coverage because the victim
was white but I guess
um these two black dudes pulled up to a
basketball court and they got into a
fight with the white guy black dude hits
the white guy and white guy falls on his
head dies they went to trial uh beat an
involuntary manslaughter charge and were
only convicted of assault there you go
it's ridiculous yeah I saw that yep
what's gonna happen with 2024 is they
don't need there to be an actual
instance of
like racism or violence the media will
just make it up garage Paul rope it's a
noose well Trump being of the Republican
nominee would just that would get people
out on the streets I mean in 26 2015 and
in early 2016 that was such a powerful
propaganda coup for antifa because you
know before their their messaging
extremist messaging has come comes out
through their pamphlets and texts and
their blogs which reaches a smaller
audience with Trump being the nominee at
that time then now they have the entire
liberal media establishment saying the
exact same prop talking points uh uh
America might elect to fascist and then
after the election America did elect a
fascia's death camps are around the
corner last deportations around the
corners I mean this sounds crazy as they
say it now but look back on the opinion
pieces and headlines that were published
in the paper is a record those were the
type of sentiments that they were
putting out
brainwash a lot of useful idiots on the
left to go out and be much more
accepting of political violence on their
side
I don't know why or how this happened
but I feel like amongst my generation
and the younger Generations coming up
political violence and vitriol is just
so high and it really rubbed me the
wrong way to see that people aren't even
accepting of just opposing beliefs it's
either my way or the highway you're evil
if you're evil I can go after you and
hurt you because I am the good guy
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time